esos son cinco datos sobre 3 la nueva
aplicación de meta que se asemeja a
Twitter uno registrarse es fácil y toma
la información directamente de tu perfil
de Instagram dos puede seguir de manera
masiva a los usuarios que ya Sigues en
Instagram y bloquea automáticamente a
las personas que ya tienes bloqueadas
allí tres funciona casi igual que
Twitter puedes dar me gusta comentar e
incluso compartir las publicaciones como
si fueran retweets 4 una vez creada la
cuenta de tres solo podrá desactivarse
pero no eliminarse para borrarla tendrás
que borrar tu cuenta de Instagram Twitch
está disponible más de 100 países pero
todavía no lo está dentro de la Unión
Europea por temas relacionados con leyes
de protección de datos y France 24 en
español también está en 3 Recuerda que
puedes seguirnos como France 24 es